the Audi q7 a heavy weight SUV known for
its comfort and suitability for long
distances but all that weight takes a
toll on sportiness the q7 screams for
more power under the hood
and that's what the Audi s q7 is
supposed to deliver says our contest at
Motta's kirat the s q7 is said to be the
sportiest and most powerful version of
the SUV but we'll see whether it's as
sporty as it claims
howdy claims that the S q7 is more
powerful faster and more comfortable
pressing the gas pedal shows that Audi
was serious when it added the s4 sport
the twin-turbo v8 diesel and electric
compressor makes the top model in this
series the world's most powerful diesel
SUV Montes is actually surprised at the
engines power he says you have to be
careful with your foot on the gas pedal
or you'll quickly find yourself
exceeding every speed limit it takes
some getting used to but it's nice to
have that power of your command the s q7
has a newly developed 4 litre twin-turbo
v8 diesel engine thanks to the electric
compressor used in a car for the first
time here it generates 320 kilowatts at
1,000 rpm it already produces 900 Newton
meters which means strong acceleration
the s q7 Sprint's from zero to 100
kilometers an hour just 4.8 seconds
howdy developer Stefan Lawrence says the
car has to conventional turbochargers
when the revs are still in the lower
range and less air is provided the
electric condensers support the system
providing more air intake and that means
acceleration
little has changed in the exterior of
the Audi s q7 the striking front and
aluminum mirror caps are standard in
outies s models the rear is dominated by
four tailpipes
the high quality interior is not only a
joy to behold it is also very intuitive
to use the electric seats offer good
lateral support another highlight the
built-in roll stabilizers which prevent
the car from tilting when accelerating
in curves
the only spokesman says the sq7 has an
actuator on each axle replacing the
conventional stabilizers the front
actuator exerts up to 1,200 Newton
meters and the rear one up to 1,000
Newton meters of counter torque against
the vehicle's body roll normally if you
speed into a curve lateral acceleration
makes the car wobble this systems
counter force keeps the car horizontally
aligned the new Audi s q7 is available
with five or seven seats the optional
third row of seats can be raised or
lowered electrically 24 assist systems
help keep this 5.0 7 meter giant on the
road
montes was initially skeptical whether
the sq7 would fulfill all its promises
but after driving it for a while he's
convinced on all points the handling is
very sporty has a very powerful engine
and gives the driver a great sense of
control so Mantha says the whole package
is well-rounded and solid of course it
isn't low priced but then it does have a
top range engine and plenty of extras
you won't find in other vehicles
Manhattan via Fela extras these in an
emphatic even gonna keep